je suis venu avec mon gilet jaune pour
bien montrer que je suis gilet jaune
fier de l'être je l'enlève je le pose
sur la table et je vous dis maintenant
que je parle en tant que citoyenne en
tant que citoyenne responsable parce que
là j'ai les jeux ne sont pas déjà dit
monsieur macro je persiste et je dis que
l'heure actuelle nous ne sommes plus
dans un état de droit nous sommes dans
un état quasi
dictature voilà exacte et des dictatures
vous en avez visités oui oui oui depuis
la maladie
je parle de ce que je vois en france
dans mon pays je suis française fière de
tout court et je vois qu'à l'heure
actuelle
monsieur a raison en disant que les non
vaccinés donc je suis non vaccinés et
pas spécialement fiers de l'aide c'est
mon choix donc je suis responsable de ce
que je veux choisir mon choix c'est
aussi mes droits fondamentaux d'accord
on est dans un pays dans lequel les
droits fondamentaux sont en train d'être
écrasés écrabouillé foulé aux pieds
donc pour le pass vaccinale
j'aimerais savoir si elle est si le
gouvernement lui propose et voilà vous
demain vous êtes vous dit aux français
et aux françaises vous oubliez les
français et françaises à se faire
puisque la question à l'état déjà
pourquoi ne faites vous pas déjà est ce
que c'est parce que vous avez peur
que d'être responsable en cas d'effets
indésirables
dans l'avenir parce qu'ils ne prennent
pas leurs responsabilités le passage
final c'est dévié la responsabilité de
l'état de l'obligation oui m'enfin ça
reste une sagesse à l'engagement ça vous
un site très fortement à vous faire
vacciner d'interposition en acier non on
oblige les gens parce que les gens qui
se sont fait vacciner pour la plupart y
en a quelques-uns qui était réellement
confiants qu'ils se sont fait vacciner
parce qu'ils ont dit on va être protégés
de ce virus a priori on n'est pas
spécialement beaucoup protégé par des
gants même protégé son utilisation
ils sont aussi vecteur de ce virus qui
peuvent le donner à n'importe qui qui
peuvent donner à n'importe qui a non
vaccinés
pas aussi le recevoir et le donner à
n'importe qui mais il peut pas dire que
il a été vaccinée j'aurais juste vous
préciser une chose en quoi vous trouvez
qu'on vous prive de droits fondamentaux
si vous avez prononcé oui le mot de
dictature que je vous le cache pas c'est
un peu choquant parce qu'on est coûteuse
à savoir ce que c'est qu'une véritable
dictature je veux dire c'est quand même
très très différent de la france de 2022
mais l'essence à côté pour le moment
qu'à tuer on croit voir une française
d'accord en quoi vous pensez que vos
droits fondamentaux sont bafoués déjà en
un non vaccinés à l'heure actuelle
effet afin ressemble à un paria tout ce
que l'on entend c'est la cause la cause
du coc vince et les non vaccinés la
cause du chômage chez les non vaccinés
la cause a sonné 10 à l'adresse des
livres dit à la mamma mia s'appelle en
dans le sol et dans les hôpitaux
les comment ça s'appelle la réanimation
mais savons nous pas la nier modem ça
madame excusez moi juste parce qu'elle
attend d eux on aura les témoignages de
chercheurs
s'est invité sur des réanimations basse
mais c'est terminale s est terminée
j'aimerais savoir on parle que on est en
en bailly on est en train d'envahir tous
les scouts leiria mais pourquoi ton
ferme et 17000 plus de 17000 y est ce
que l'on a viré autant d'infirmières le
problème c'est pourquoi le problème est
que s'il y aurait plus de place et en
réa s'il y avait plus de l'île madame
vous trouvez que vous pensez qu aller en
réa c'est un parcours de santé est-ce
qu'on peut juste à voir les chiffres si
vous voulez j'avais demandé n'en
attendais parce que mon nom mais je
voudrais on a on a un professeur émérite
sur ce plateau donc qui s'y connaît dans
cette matière
s'il vous plaît juste disponible oui
parce que la
vanne ou les commenter aujourd'hui c'est
ça madame et le droits fondamentaux de
tous
les stylos graphique il est très très
clair c'est en orange sont l'innovation
avec mon fils son aspect avec beaucoup
de respect madame je devais je vais
m'adresser à vous et vous dire un petit
peu à la situation sur les disparitions
de l'île et lee qui ont été enlevés ok
mais aujourd'hui nous avons une
situation particulière particulière ok
on verra après il faudra il ya une
élection présidentielle j'espère que
aura des modifications au niveau
sanitaire en vie quoi aujourd'hui moi je
vous invite à venir à la pitié
salpêtrière dans le service de maladies
infectieuses et de voir quelle est la
réalité aujourd'hui je dire après sur au
micro ondes aujourd'hui en termes de
réanimation vous savez quel est l'âge
moyen en réanimation madame il est
autour de 60 ans ce qui veut dire que
l'âge médian ce qui veut dire que vous
avez autant de personnes au delà de 60
ans en dessous de 60 ans donc je veux
dire attention la notion c'est
uniquement les personnes âgées
aujourd'hui dans les services de
réanimation je parlerai de l'hôpital
parce que c'est très important de dire
l'hospitalisation traditionnelle et
également les services de réanimation de
soins critiques en réanimation on est
autour de 4000 je suis très optimiste
voyez sur le futur mais je pourrais vous
en dire quelques mots après aujourd'hui
c'est une majorité de delta mais c'est
une majorité de personnes non vaccinées
et les personnes vaccinées ce sont des
personnes qui sont immunodéprimés auprès
desquels le vaccin marche beaucoup moins
bien et quelques personnes qui ont
attendu si vous voulez après les deux
doses et qui effectivement ne sont pas
couverts on a quand même en est à 120
étaient presque 122 mille morts
aujourd'hui c'est une réalité également
le service dans lequel je travaille
maladies infectieuses à paris à la pitié
salpêtrière
aujourd'hui nous sommes pleins ou vides
au vide moi je m'occupe de sida je
m'occupe de tuberculose cette maladie
infectieuse si demain vous faites une
pneumonie qui n'est pas la peau vide ou
une autre affection parce qu'on est en
train de déprogrammer j'espère que ça va
vite s'arrêter vous savez ce que ça
signifie la déprogrammation madame je
vais vous donner trois exemples monsieur
zéribi il a une douleur dans la poitrine
demain normalement je lui fais une
coronarographie on lui fait une
coronarographie très vite et si si si un
petit problème on va lui mettre deux
stents et le problème est réglé un
monsieur je suis désolé on a fermé des
salles d'opération il n'ya pas
d'anesthésié tous locaux vides 19
attendait entre temps dans trois
semaines on va vous la faire vous faites
à l'infarctus vous madame on va vous
faire une coloscopie où je le souhaite
pas je donne des exemples les
personnaliser non non non mais
non mais je veux y arrive demande si on
peut inverser
japonais de quoi supporter madame et je
polémique pas j'essaie de vous expliquer
quelle est la réalité que nous vivons la
coloscopie ça permet de détecter d'une
manière très très précoce en cancer du
côlon mais donc plus on le 13
précocément plus on a des chances
effectivement de
régler ce problème les coloscopies on
les retarde énormément donc on va
laisser passer quelques cancers qui va
être un stade plus développés
mammographie de même c'est une réalité
madame ça sans compter que en
réanimation qui sont vraiment occupé
vous avez les schémas par des non
vaccinés si demain monsieur naulleau un
accident de la route de trottinettes je
ne sais pas non non c'est c'est aussi
une boutade il doit rentrer en
réanimation voilà alors moi je suis pas
pour je moi je ne demande même pas je
traite les vacciner les non-vaccinés
puis peu importe je suis contre cette
stigmatisation je vous dire mieux ce
qu'a dit le président de la république
parce que je lui ai dit à plusieurs
reprises
on emmerde pas les non vaccinés il ya
des antilles vax réel avec des avec des
théories comploter ce que vous voulez
mais il ya des non vaccinés que je
respecte tout à fait qu'ils ont leurs
raisons